ja wir kommen zu aktuellen vorlesungen
heute geht es um die politik der
digitalität wir sind heute in der
vorletzten sitzung ist noch eine sitzung
nächste woche und dann ist auch schon
dieses semester herum
hier noch kurz ein paar informationen
zur heutigen plan
zunächst werde ich einen rückblick auf
die letzte sitzung geben in der wir uns
mit der anthropologie der digitalität
fast sagen und dabei vor allem auf das
problem des trans humanismus angegangen
sind dann mache ich oben rechts gleich
noch den link auf youtube dann ein
dann kommen wir auf das eigentliche
thema der heutigen vorlesung nämlich
politik der digitalität dabei werden
verschiedene phänomene im zentrum stehen
vor allem natürlich das internet was ich
wie sie schon wissen als virtuelle
handlungsraum stimme aber wir werden uns
auch mit der frage nach künstlicher
intelligenz und politik befassen und das
online manifesto von luciano flori die
kurz kennenlernen außerdem werden wir
die frage nach einer digitalen
aufklärung aufwerfen und fragen
inwiefern wir überhaupt in zeiten der
digitalität so etwas wie eine digitale
aufklärung benötigen und was darunter
überhaupt zu verstehen ist aber auch wie
wir eben dann dieser problematik der
fehlenden aufklärung sofern sie digital
bedingt ist entgehen können und dann
gibt es zum schluss noch einen ausblick
auf die nächste und letzte sitzung in
diesem semester nämlich zur zukunft des
internets und da soll es und das beta
version geben das sage ich auch noch
ganz am ende etwas dazu jetzt aber ein
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung hier
hatten wir verschiedene begriffe gibt
macht singularität und exponential ead
sind ganz wichtig sie kennen dieses buch
jetzt zur genüge
ich will ja auch nicht mehr groß drauf
eingehen entscheiden ist einfach dieses
exponentielle wachstum also je mehr zeit
wir hier zurücklegen des zu
beschleunigen tag steigt hier die kurve
an und daraus wird dann eben hergeleitet
irgendeiner zukünftigen fazit vielleicht
um das jahr 2100 um einen so steilen
anstieg gibt dass hier etwas neues
energie rdx der letzten sitzung hatten
wir den sockel begriff der im ergänzt
problematisiert ich selbst habe ihn auch
verwendet das muss man immer ein
bisschen aufpassen dass man nicht so
davon redet da findet eine technische
entwicklung statt technologisch und
irgendwann wenn sie nur komplex genug
ist dann entsteht etwas neues so wie aus
der pistole geschossen das muss man
immer genau begründen und da sehe ich
eben ein problem bei ray kurzweil diese
allzu häufige rede von im agents auch
wenn man diesen begriff kaum herum kommt
natürlich in anderen kontexten auch der
schalten hier blick auf die
philosophische diskussion von
selbstbewussten maschinen zu
unreflektiert verwendet zu werden ist
dieses buch so dass ich mich auch
bezogen habe die ages bildschirm
erschien zeitalter geistiger maschinen
obertitel one computers y intelligentes
und die spannende frage ob computer
nicht nur intelligent sein können
sondern auch die menschliche intelligenz
übertreffen können natürlich eine sehr
spekulative frage die nicht so trotz
nichtsdestotrotz sehr spannend ist und
anregend ist und wir sollten uns wie ich
finde immer auch in der philosophie mit
gedanken experimenten beschäftigen
doch was kurz zum transport muss dass es
dieses logo ich hatte darauf verwiesen
dass wikipedia also von lateinisch trans
jenseits über hinaus wo man muss
menschlich grenzen menschlicher
möglichkeiten seien sie intellektuell
physisch oder psychisch aber sicherlich
auch moralisch hatte ich hinzugefügt
durch den einsatz technologisch
verfahren erweitern will
erweiterung ist ein punkt übertreffen
oder etwas ganz neues dadurch erzeugen
der andere punkt und in diese richtung
geht eben kurz mal ich hatte dann eine
kritik an diesem
transnistrischen konzept vorgestellt von
julian nida-rümelin den er als digitalen
humanismus versteht sein ansatz eine
ethik für das zeitalter künstlicher
intelligenz hier ein zitat ich finde
dieses buch sehr lesenswert auch wenn
ich nicht alle teams zustimmen die
gründe habe ich in der letzten sitzung
auch benannt zitat wir entwickeln in
diesem buch die grundzüge eines
digitalen um an diesen als alternative
zu dem was man etwas vereinfachend als
kann rallye ideologie bezeichnen kann
diese hängt mit der uramerikanischen
puritanisch geprägt mit lösungs hoffnung
zusammen eine welt der reihen und
gerechten zu schaffen die schmutz und
finde hinter sich gelassen haben da kann
man sich natürlich fragen ob es dieses
ideal des trans humanismus nicht schon
vor der europäischen besiedlung der
vereinigten staaten von nordamerika gab
ob nicht auch solche mythologischen
figuren wie prometheus diese richtung
deuten oder frankenstein von mary
shelley ein sehr lesenswerter roman
nicht darin auch diese ganzen punkte
schon
angeschlagen sind falkenstein dann
natürlich nach der amerikanischen
besiedlung durch europa wenn die
europäer aber das ist jedenfalls auch
eine lange tradition die man immer im
blick haben sollte vor allem in der
literatur in dem fiktiven texten wo eben
auch die denkt möglichkeiten literarisch
erkundet werden das möchte ich hier noch
ein paar probleme des transponders
benennen die mir sehr zentral zu sein
scheint die trans humanismus orientiert
sich an der biologischen
evolutionstheorie und er weiter diese
durch eine technologische
evolutionstheorie in welcher technik und
mensch immer mehr konvergieren also die
technologische evolution setzt die
natürliche evolution konsequent fordern
der trans humanismus versteht insofern
technologie als etwas sich normativ
selbst rechtfertigen dass also
technologie wird nicht nur als ein
unwesentliches äußeres phänomen
gefasster etwas was uns menschen
gewissermaßen antreibt zur
weiterentwicklung nicht nur uns in die
liedern sondern die menschheit als
solchen
und dadurch wird technologie einerseits
zu etwas sehr normativen allerdings auch
etwas der metaphysische und hier wird im
gleichen zug wie ich finde die
problematik ausgeblendet die mit
technologie immer einher gehen kann also
technologie wird hier nur dem
gesichtspunkt des positiv entwickeln
gesehen trans man ismus besitzt
ausserdem spekulative und ideologische
züge die darüber liegenden das
zurechtzurücken welle ideologie der
trans humanismus verstehen personale
identität im sinne von software ich
hatte da auch ein zitat gebracht von ray
kurzweil von software und reduziert
somit den menschen auf bloße technik
kurzweil sprach davon dass wir in der
zukunft unseren geist unserer unsere
gehirn in software umbilden und dann
immer auf neue hardware portieren
hardware ist austauschbar hardware ist
vergänglich falls sie physisch ist die
software hingegen lässt sich immer
weiter
weiterführen im sinne einer personale
identität und wenn eben die software
konstant bleibt und die technik konnte
er wechselt aber konstant eben auch
wechselt so ist eben auch der gedanke
einer viel engeren existenz möglich das
führt natürlich dann auch zur
spekulation mit blick auf
unsterblichkeit und verwalter ganz
interessant ist dabei jetzt der punkt
dass hier plötzlich alte fragen nach
personale identität wie sie zb bei john
glock den siebzehnten jahrhundert
zentrale waren der eben gesagt hat
unsere personal ead unsere identität
besteht in der kontinuität des
selbstbewusstseins des bewusstseins dass
diese alten fragen plötzlich in neuem
gewand revitalisiert werden nämlich
durch die entwicklung der digitalen
technik das ist ganz spannend das ist
ein genereller zug der digitalität alte
fragen alte philosophische fragen werden
plötzlich neu motiviert durch diese
technik und das deutet darauf hin dass
es sich dabei eben nicht nur um technik
handelt eine technologie sondern um eine
sphäre die es erlaubt altes neu zu
formulieren also ein technologischer
zugriff wäre hier in meinen augen
verkürzt aus philosophischer
sich jetzt noch kurz ein paar
charakterzüge zur anthropologie der
digitalität wie ich sie eben und gerne
entwickeln würde in dieser vorlesung
anthropologie und digitalität also wie
verhält sich der mensch zur digitalität
die stehen einen engen verhältnis
zueinander welches nicht durch die
opposition mensch wie das technik oder
mensch wer das maschine charakterisiert
ich möchte gegen diese opposition
argumentieren wenn digitalität und das
ist jetzt das entscheidet das
entscheidende argument wenn digitalität
wie ich sie verstehe durch den begriff
der virtuellen realität bestimmt ist
dann muss auch die anthropologie vom
begriff der digitalität her verstanden
werden virtuelle realität wird so als
eine dimension und existenz weise des
menschen sichtbar die in seiner freiheit
besteht also wenn digitalität ganz eng
etwas mit virtueller realität zu tun hat
und menschliche freiheit auch dann
kommen diese zwei bereiche mensch und
digitalität immer mehr in einen
zusammenhang der eben nicht opposition
nicht lose technologien ich bloßes
instrument bedeutet zur verwirklichung
von freiland diese freiheit ist eine
kreative freiheit die es erlaubt
vorhandene und bekannte dinge auf eine
andere weise neu zu realisieren wird
würde realität bedeutet dass man zb wie
es jetzt sie machen seminare und
vorlesungen situation durch die
digitalisierung neu realisiert nicht nur
simuliert sondern eben durch diese
digitale transformation auf ganz neue
entwicklungen kommt wie zum beispiel
direkt wie zum beispiel das einblenden
einbeziehen von anderen medien
unmittelbar nicht nur sinne von
nachschlagen einem buch diese vernetzung
spielt eine große rolle bekommen da noch
heute darauf zu sprechen und das scheint
mir eben darauf hinzudeuten dass sich
hierbei nicht um eine simulation der
herkömmlichen generell handelt sondern
um eine neuartige realisiert die mit
kreativität und menschlicher freiheit
sehr viel zu tun habe das habe ich ein
paar leitfragen für die heute ist sie zu
erstens gibt es ein menschenrecht
auf internet zu kommen das steht jetzt
alles im kontext der frage nach der
politik der digitalität und die es heute
geht gibt es eine digitale
menschenrechte und menschen schlicht
richten sollte es eine globale internet
regierung geben benötigen wir eine
digitale aufklärung und falls ja wie ist
diese zu denken und durchzuführen und
mit dieser letzten frage nach der
digitalen aufklärung möchte ich heute
zunächst befassen das schreibt ein ganz
wichtiges thema zu sein welches uns
philosophin und philosophen besonders
betrifft da können wir noch wirklich
etwas beitragen zur technologischen
entwicklung der digitalisierung digitale
aufklärung ist also das erste thema der
heutigen vorlesung und da möchte ich
ihnen ein buch kurz vorstellen was ich
für sehr lesenswert erachten von oz
ebooks und tim cole
digitale aufklärung warum uns das
internet gemacht im hanser verlag
erschien 2013 schon einige jahre her
dennoch total zentral darüber dieser
schnelllebigen zeit der digitalen
entwicklung dieses buch hat eine andere
perspektive auf die digitale technik vor
allem auf das internet wie der
untertitel stand sagt als es zum
beispiel diese bücher hatten die ich
ihnen auch schon vorgestellt hat in
einer der ersten sitzung wo es um
digitale demenz ging manfred spitzer als
beispiel genannt also hier dass es eine
wesentlich positivere sicht auf die
digitalisierung die aber dennoch
versucht eine kritische einstellung dazu
zu entwickeln und zu zeigen wie wir mit
diesem neuen medien am besten umgehen
ich möchte jetzt hier aus ein paar
zitate vorlesen die mir besonders
zentral zu sein scheint kann dieses buch
basiert fehlen die tat sowie
digitalisierung immer beschleunigung
bedeutet bedeutet vernetzung dem auch
mit digitalisierung bringt immer
verändern also beschleunigung und
veränderung die veränderung liegt
geradezu im wesen der vernetzung
begründet ein gutes beispiel dafür
die vernetzung zur veränderung führt
stammt von vint cerf einem der erfinder
des tcp ip protokoll
es uns so mit einem der väter des
internets ich mach oben rechts noch ein
link zu der sitzung wo wir uns der
philosophie des internets und seine
geschichte und struktur genauer befasst
haben was passiert fragte selbst wenn
wir einen internetfähigen kühlschrank
mit einer ebenfalls internetfähigen
personenwaage vernetzt es verändert sich
etwas sie kommen abends nach hause und
der kirchen ist nicht mehr zu öffnen
oder er enthält nur noch diätkost weil
die beiden sich einig geworden sind dass
sie lieber ein paar tage abnehmen sollen
das ist jetzt natürlich nur ein
ironisches spiel aber es zeigt doch dass
hier durch die vernetzung ganz
verschiedene aspekte plötzlich ins spiel
kommt die wir sonst wenn wir ihr
sukzessiv den jahr voranschreiten so
nicht erledigen können also es hat etwas
von dieser netzwerke und simultan itt zu
tun dass die modernität struktur die der
digitalisierung zukunft das finde ich
zwar sehr treffende charakterisierung
beschleunigung aber noch wichtiger halte
ich die vernetzung und verändert weitere
zitate aus diesem buch
digitalisierung und vernetzung sind also
die komplementären kräfte die die
exponentielle beschleunigung nicht nur
der technologieentwicklung sondern
unserer gesamten lebensweise auf
individueller wie gesellschaftlicher
ebene vorantreiben willkommen in der ad
hoc gesellschaft finde ich auch sehr
treffend hier wird wieder auf die
exponentielle beschleunigung verwiesen
das macht und ray kurzweil und seine
säkularität these aber hier ist dagegen
jetzt nicht von plötzlich intelligenten
maschinen die rede sondern von einer
lebensweise oder lebensform die
grundlegend durchwirkt wird die
grundlegend betroffen ist und die eben
auch neue realitäten und schafft durch
diese digitalisierung die mit
beschleunigung und veränderung oder
vernetzung eben ganz eng zusammenhängt
das waren nicht nur auf individueller
ebene wie hier gesagt wird sind eben sie
betrifft uns alle
machen sie tat mit den folgenden thesen
die werde ich jetzt gleich vorstellen es
gibt nämlich zehn thesen in diesem buch
entwickelt werden mit den folgenden
thesen wollen wir die autoren ganz im
geiste der klassischen europäischen
aufklärung einen denkprozess einleiten
und darüber hinaus einen
gesellschaftlichen diskurs anstoßen es
geht uns darum dass neu dass wir heute
immer kürzeren abständen erleben auch
als etwas wirklich neues zu denken uns
also jenseits herkömmlicher vorstellung
und begriffe zu bewegen und so gerüstet
in einem gesellschaftlichen diskurs
eintreten zu können auch und gerade
darüber ob und wie uns dieses neue
nützlich sein könnte oder ob wir es als
untaugliche weg besser auf die müllhalde
der geschichte
expediert zurück auch eine sehr
treffende frage geht es hier wirklich um
etwas neues bei diesen ganzen
entwicklung ich glaube ja und die
autoren glauben dass auch und deswegen
finde ich dieses buch auch so zentral
weil sie sich nicht nur mit
spekulationen auf halten wir es wollen
und nicht nur mit einseitigem
medienkritik wie es eben manfred spitzer
vertritt auch nicht mit zu einem
humanistischen mittelweg wenn du dann
ideen vertritt wir sehen das positiv
neue ganz klar versuchen das aber
trotzdem
philosophisch kritisch zu betrachten
also hier scheint mir also ein wirklich
guter mittelweg 1 geschlagen zu werden
angesichts dieser verschiedenen optionen
von haltungen die wir gegenüber der
digitalisierung einigen kann jetzt
möchte ich diese zehn thesen zu einer
digital aufklärung wie sie in diesem
buch entwickelt werden kurz präsentieren
und auch diskutieren oder kommentieren
zunächst these 1 alles was sich
digitalisieren lässt wird digitalisiert
alles was ich vernetzen lässt das
vernetzt und das verändert alles hier
würde ich zustimmen wenn die
digitalisierung wie es die autoren
argumentieren wirklich fortschritt
bedeutet die autoren argumentieren hier
vor allem auch von einer ökonomischen
perspektive her wenn digitalisierung ein
trend ist der sich durchsetzt sowie die
elektrifizierung ich hatte da auch eine
vorlesung dazu gemacht nach oben rechts
blinken sowie die elektrifizierung also
wenn es nicht um einen paradigmenwechsel
handelt der alle bereiche transformiert
und zwar disruptive also wirklich
radikal revolutionär dann wird das auch
so kommen dann wird alles vernetzt und
dann wird sich alles durch die
vernetzung verändert dem habe stimme ich
unbedingt vorbehaltlos zu these 2
digitalisierung und vernetzung sind kein
schnupfen sie gehen nicht wieder weg
auch hier scheint mir das sehr treffend
formuliert sein es handelt sich hier um
diskussionen wie damals die
elektrifizierung wie die dampfmaschine
rie das sind alles faktoren die unsere
gesellschaft grundlegend verändert haben
und hinter die wir nicht mehr
zurückkommen können ohne unsere freiheit
extrem einzuschränken ohne uns ins
abseits zu stellen ich will nicht sagen
dass jeder mensch das recht hat auf eine
nicht digitalisierte welt das ist immer
noch die entscheidung jeder einzelperson
aber es wird sehr schwer wird immer
weniger gründe haben ein solches nicht
mit digitalisierung in berührung
stehendes leben zu führen die gründe
werden immer weniger aber das recht
bleibt natürlich immer da es gibt keine
pflicht zur digitalisierung so das würde
ich auf jeden fall auch sein aber die
gründe werden weniger these 3 die
digitale und die reale welt durchdringen
sich immer mehr das verändert beide mit
rasender geschwindigkeit und einem ist
der unfallstelle vorstellbaren maß hier
habe ich jetzt etwas zu kritisieren sie
können sich denken die gegenüberstellung
von digitaler und realer welt das
suggeriert wieder dass es hier virtuelle
realität und wirklich realität gibt
dagegen habe ich in vielen vorlesungen
argumentiert das virtuelle ist nur eine
form von realität weswegen sich die
beiden hier gar nicht durchdringen
müssen oder nicht im gegeneinander in
opposition zu stellen sind sondern sie
gehen ineinander über im sinne einer
begrifflichen ordnung und nicht im sinne
dessen dass wir plötzlich mehr
simulationen haben und plötzlich die
simulation für realität halten drauf
komme ich aber nachher noch genau zu
sprechen wenn ich dieses onlive meine
festung von luciano von gideon kollegen
diskutieren werde aber auch dieser these
stimme ich natürlich zu c c4
digitalisierung und vernetzung schaffen
technisch und gesellschaftsbild
kulturell und wissenschaftlich neue
bedingung sie gilt es in kategorien zu
fassen und als qualitäten zu verstehen
sehr schön finde ich hier das hier auf
das dürfen es auf die notwendigkeit
neuer kategorien oder begrifflichkeiten
hingewiesen wenn es veränderungen gibt
müssen wir die veränderung auf dem
begriff bringen und dazu ist auch die
philosophie unter anderem tag und ihr
wird gesagt diese veränderungen sind
nicht nur quantitativ zu verstehen also
schneller höher weiter
das macht nicht nur alles schneller sas
verändert auch alles durch virtuelle
realität und deswegen brauchen wir auch
eine qualitative analyse dieser phänomen
das stimmt mich auch zähle zu käse fünf
massenmedien verlieren mit dieser
entwicklung nach 150 jahren ihre
gemeinschaft und identität stiften
funktionen dadurch kann die
kommunikation gewissermaßen zu ihren
ursprung zurück zum inter
personalaustausch der heute allerdings
zunehmend digital und medial vermittelt
stattfindet hier ist natürlich zu denen
an zeitungen fernsehen und
zeitung gibt's natürlich seit 150 jahren
fernsehen nicht so lang als massenmedium
ich verstehe mich auch zu warum weil die
medien dieses vermitteln dem moment
immer mehr verlieren ich brauche nicht
ein papier wir kaufen zum kiosk gehen da
steht das mit schwarzer schrift auf sind
dieser austausch diese verwicklung
geschieht durch das internet immer
unmittelbarer fast schon überhaupt nicht
vermittelt das ist auch mein argument
des internet ist kein medium das in
virtueller handlungsraum also der
mediale charakter der tritt zunehmend
zurück das würde ich hier noch
präzisieren hinzufügen t6
digitalisierung und vernetzung
produzieren eine dramatische
beschleunigung und destruktiv
entwicklung von technologien und medien
diese gilt es nicht zu beherrschen
sondern zu verstehen und zu genießen
hier sehen sie jetzt gibt's eine
kritische wendung gegen diese sehr
häufig an sie trifft im topos dass man
die technik beherrschen müsse sonst
beherrschte sie einen das ist ein sehr
häufiges argument dass nicht auch
durchaus nachvollziehen kann aber hier
wird eben nicht jetzt mensch und technik
in eigene position gebracht und ein
technokratisches verhältnisse die
technik herrscht nicht und der mensch
herrscht auch nicht technokratisch
sondern es geht darum sie zu verstehen
um zu genießen genießen heißt wiederum
technik technologie werden bestandteil
nahtlose bestandteil unseres
selbstverständlichen umgang im alltag
lebenswelt nicht bedeutsam diese sieben
das leben einer derart grundsätzlich
anderen welt wird damit komplexe aber
nicht komplizierter sondern einfach auch
sehr originelle idee es häufig denkt man
ja mit komplexität zunahme geht
kompliziertheit lang her mit komplexität
technischer geht immer mehr einher dass
wir die technik nicht verstehen dass die
technik uns etwas also etwas fremdes uns
beherrschen das entgegensteht hier wird
es die gegenteilige these getrieben es
wird wohl es komplexer wird einfacher
dem stimme ich auch zu warm wird es
einfacher bei wir digitale technik im
sinne virtuelle realität verwenden eben
im sinne etwas was uns unmittelbar
angeht was uns als menschen wesentlich
ist dadurch wird es einfacher diese acht
auch der mensch und sein denken
verändern sich grundsätzlich der
funktioniert und denkt zunehmend digital
und vernetzt und das in echtzeit hier
muss man sich jetzt natürlich frage was
heißt jetzt funktionieren und denken auf
digitale weise dass diese mir nicht ganz
klar geworden ich würde hier meine these
wieder stattdessen entgegensetzen dass
ich eben sage es geht um virtuelle
realität der mensch erweitert sein
handlungsspielraum nicht im digitalen
sind im virtuellen die große
konzentration auf das digitale er hat in
meinen augen blick auf das worum es
eigentlich geht nämlich virtuelle
realität
aber diese echtzeit charakter scheint
mir dennoch wichtig zu zeigen wir
brauchen nicht mehr so lange zu warten
wie wir es bei medien tour mussten einen
brief schreiben eine zeitung lesen wo
die informationen auch immer nur von
gestern sind oder schon einige stunden
alt wir haben es unmittelbar damit zu
tun das scheint mir sehr wichtig zu sein
von der these these neu begriffe und
erfahrungen aus der analogen
vergangenheit werden diese sich
dynamisch weiterentwickelt und gegenwart
immer weniger gerecht sie wirken in der
aktuellen debatte ebenso lang lief wie
unpassend oder überheblich in jedem fall
aber hilflos dem stimmig vorbehaltslos
mit dazu können sie sich denken aus dem
was wir bisher schon hatten in dieser
vorlesung wir dürfen nicht einfach
begriffe aus einer anderen zeit oder
besser gesagt das eine andere dimension
des lebens weltlichen umgangs des
analogen umgangs wir dürfen die nicht
einfach eins zu eins auf diese
neuentwicklung betrag wir haben zwar
diese tendenz dazu aber es wird den
neuen entwicklungen nicht immer gerecht
wir sollten es sicherlich immer fragen
wie fern sich eine analogie herstellen
ist wir sollten aber immer offen sein um
neue begriffe zu prägen und das setzt
sich dass dieses ziel setzt sich eben
auch dieses buch wenn auch nicht in
alleiniger philosophische absicht habe
eben auch
these 10 wir brauchen eine digitale
aufklärung neu und selbst gebracht
gedachte kategorien die allein diese
grundsätzlich veränderten welt gerecht
werden können nur damit können wir diese
welt kritisch reflektieren und produktiv
nutzen
hier stellt sich jetzt die frage wird
diese neue und selbst gedachten
kategorien wie die auszusehen haben und
hier ist die philosophie gerade wieder
am zuge hier hat sie wirklich ein
bereich wo sie kreativ und passend zur
digitalisierung entwicklung etwas zu
sagen hat und das möchte ich jetzt mal
ein bisschen
weiterentwickeln noch ein zitat zum
schluss
in einer ähnlichen situation des
fundamentalen wandels befand sich die
menschheit schon einmal gegen ende des
18 jahrhunderts erstarrte
gesellschaftliche und wirtschaftliche
verhältnisse wurden über den haufen
geworfen das zwischen klassischer logik
und mittelalterliche plastik gefangen
denken war hoffnungslos überfordert von
der gewaltigen dynamik der veränderung
angesichts dieses klassischen dilemmas
bestand immanuel kants antwort in seiner
maxime jederzeit selbst zu denken ist
die aufklärung von der gleichen aufgabe
stehen wir heute mit der digitalen
aufgegangen hier wird jetzt natürlich
ein zug gebracht im markant dem
klassischen denker der aufklärung der
hier noch ein bisschen größer lich und
oberflächlich bleibt ist ja auch kein
philosophisches buch und das wollen wir
heute in der heutigen vorlesung etwas
erweitern nachholen das heißt wir wollen
jetzt erst mal fragen was immanuel kant
eigentlich genau über aufklärung zu
sagen hat und dann uns fragen ob wir im
gigantischen geist auch eine aufklärungs
theorie auf lebensphilosophie für die
digitale zeit die digitalität entwickeln
können der wir immer mehr existieren das
ist ein bild von ihm machen kann hat im
18 jahrhundert gelebt 1724 1804
und hat im jahr 1784 eine ganz bekannte
schrift mit dem titel beantwortung der
frage passen ist aufklärung verfasst und
dieses zitat kennen sie sicherlich alle
jetzt trotzdem noch mal vorlesen dass es
ganz zu beginn die kurze definition
aufklärung ist der ausgang des menschen
aus seiner selbstverschuldeten
unmündigkeit
unmündigkeit ist das unvermögen sich
seines verstandes ohne leitung eines
anderen zu beginnen selbst verschuldet
ist diese unmündigkeit wenn die ursache
der selben nicht am mangel des
verstandes sind der erschließung und des
mutes liegt sich seiner ohne leitung
eines anderen zu bedienen sapere aude
habe mut dich deines eigenen verstandes
zu bedienen ist also der wahlspruch der
aufklärung
also es geht also hier um dass wir es
mit der unmündigkeit zu tun haben eine
undichtigkeit die aber selbst
verschuldet erst als wir sind selbst
daran beteiligt unmündig zu werden jetzt
müssen wir uns eben fragen wie seht ihr
die unmündigkeit aus die digitale und
wie kann ein digitaler ausgang aus der
digitalen mündigkeit erfolgen und dann
haben wir eine frage beantwortet nach
der digitalen aufklärung es wäre es
diese übertragung auf die heute die
situation
ich lese noch zwei zitate vor von kante
aus dieser schrift faulheit und
fähigkeit sind die ursachen warum ein so
großer teil der menschen nachdem sie die
natur längst von fremder leitung
freigesprochen der noch gerne zeitlebens
unmündigkeit und warum jetzt anderen
erleichtert sich zu deren vormund
aufzuwerfen es ist zur bequem unmöglich
zu sein habe ich ein buch das für mich
verstand hat ein seelsorger der für mich
gewissen hat ein arzt der für mich die
hecke urteilt und so weiter so brauche
ich mich ja nicht selbst zu bemühen ich
habe nicht nötig zu denken wenn ich nur
bezahlen kann andere werden das
vertriebliche geschäft schon für mich
übernehmen in ganz interessante geht es
um die arbeitsteilung auch die moderne
um die fürsorge die gewissermaßen
outgesourced wird so kann man jetzt ja
sagen mit moderner begrifflichkeit hier
hatte jetzt das buch genannt also hier
kommen jetzt eine implizite medienkritik
ins spiel ein buch das für mich verstand
hat und hier haben wir jetzt natürlich
einen bezug zum internet ja das könnte
man in der heutigen zeit genauso sah
habe ich ein internetzugang der für mich
verstand hat der seelsorger könnte sogar
auch im internet zu finden sagen ja und
der arzt auch ich kann ja googeln wenn
es mal irgendwo zwickt gebe ich das in
google ein und dann habe ich dem
virtuellen zurück ins internet oder die
ärzte also das kann man jetzt hier alles
sehr gut aufs internet beziehen der
zitat es ist also für jeden einzelnen
menschen schwer sich aus der ihm beinahe
zur natur geworden unmündigkeit
herauszuarbeiten
er hat sie sogar lieb gefallen ist vor
der hand wirklich unfähig sich seines
eigenen verstandes zu bedienen weil man
ihm niemals den versuch davon machen
ließ der satzung und formeln diese
mechanischen werkzeuge eines
vernünftigen gekauft oder vielmehr
missbrauch seiner natur gaben sind
diffus schellen einer immerwährenden
unmöglichkeit wer sich wäre sie ja auch
abwürfe würde dennoch auch über den
schmalsten karben eine nur unsicheren
sprungturm weil er zu der gleichen
freier bewegung nicht gewöhnt ist daher
gibt es nur wenige denen es gelungen ist
durch eigene bearbeitung ihres geistes
sich aus der unmündigkeit heraus zu
wickeln und der noch einen sicheren gang
zu tun hier wird das ganze jetzt
metaphorisch oder sogar allegorisch
bedeutet es geht um einen gang
den mann sicher tun muss und der
bedeutet eben aufklären also satzungen
vor mit diesem mechanischen werkzeuge
also hier kommt auch wieder diesen
mechanistische metaphern spielen und wir
müssen uns jetzt fragen wie wir aus
dieser unmündigkeit die wir natürlich
auch im digitalen raum haben
herauskommen hier kommt noch ein letztes
zitat dass ich ihnen nicht verschweigen
möchte kann es aufklärungs schrift zitat
zu dieser aufklären wird nichts
erfordert als freiheit und zwar die
unschädliche unter allem was nur
freiheit heißt nämlich die von seiner
vernunft in allen stücken öffentlichen
gebrauch zu machen hier kommt jetzt
wieder eine interaktive funktionen spiel
aber ganz wichtig ihm auch der freiheits
pickel und vor diesem hintergrund möchte
ich jetzt heute mal versuchen eine
digitale aufklärung noch philosophische
zu entwickeln als es die autoren in
diesem buch über digitale aufklärung
getan haben weil sie einen stärker
ökonomischen hintergrund haben zunächst
möchte ich die frage aufwerfen worin
besteht eigentlich die digitale
mündigkeit
zu der wir einen ausgang finden wollen
hier wäre jetzt ein paar punkte das
ließe sich beliebig fortsetzen ich halte
die für die wichtigsten erstens wir
nehmen alle informationen im internet
für bare münze steht doch da was da
steht wird schon richtig sein weiterer
punkt wir begreifen die entwicklung der
digitalisierung als einen retten ein
technologisches phänomen das ist jetzt
nicht so ganz klar dass das
unmöglichkeit heißt ich werde aber noch
genauer drauf kommen wochen punkt der in
meinen augen für unsere digitale
unmündigkeit spricht wir verwenden die
digitalisierung als ein instrument
punkt mir verwende digitalisieren nur
als ein medium wie verstehen sie wo als
ein medium und dass der nächste punkt
scheint mir ganz zentral zu sein die
unterscheidet nicht zwischen simulation
und physische realität zum beispiel wenn
ich eben glaube dass wenn ich da ein
computerspiel spiele dass es die
wirkliche die physische realität ist
dass es einige form von digitalen
mündigkeit aber jetzt auch noch ein
weiterer punkt wir unterscheiden nicht
zwischen simulation und virtuelle
realität dieser punkt ist nicht ganz so
deutlich wie im falle von
computersimulationen physische realität
aber der scheinbar noch zentraler zu
seiner dies scheint mir der zentralen
punkt bei unsere digitalen unmündigkeit
dass sein wir scheinen nicht die
potenziale der digitalisierung für
virtuelle realität zu sehen wir scheint
das ganze was mit digitalisierung
einhergeht nur für simulation zahlen das
internet nur als ein medium nur als
simulierte kommunikation nur als
simulierte handlung und ich halt echt
klappt und das scheint mir eine form von
unmöglichkeit zu sein worin besteht
jetzt der ausgang aus der digital
unmündigkeit zu wie ich sie sehe das
wird meine thesen die kann man sehr wohl
treffen diskutieren das die die ihn auch
zu provokationen dann mache ich keinen
hehl draus wir verstehen das internet
nicht als ein bloßes instrument oder
medium das wäre in meinen augen digital
unmündig wir verstehen es als einen
virtuellen handlungsraum als wir
gestehen ihm eine lebensweltliche
realität zu das scheint mir eine
ausgangs möglichkeit aus der digitalen
mündigkeit zusagen noch einen weiteren
punkt wie wir der digital unmöglichkeit
meines erachtens entgehen können wir
verstehen unsere handeln im internet
nicht als bloße simulationen die
illusionen oder fiktion sind als
virtuelle realitäten für die wir
verantwortung ganz einfach kann man sich
gegen wenn alles im internet nur
simulationen illusion fraktion ist dann
kann ich ja da tun was ich will das wird
ja schon nicht so schlimm sein so ist es
eben nicht wenn wir das internet als
virtuelle handlungsraum auffassen indem
wir in unsere freien entscheidung
agieren dann müssen wir dafür natürlich
auch verantworten
noch eine möglichkeit ist ausgangs wir
verstehen die digitalisierung nicht als
beherrschende technik sind als
ermöglichung grund von freiheiten im
cine virtueller realität da plötzlich
jetzt anderen eine dieser thesen der
digitalen aufklärung das eben
digitalisierung nicht uns beherrscht und
wir sie auch nicht beherrschen sondern
dass sie einfach alles einfacher macht
und qualitativ neue sich darum
schließlich wir verstehen das internet
nicht als spielzeug sind als
grundbedürfnis auf welches alle menschen
ein recht haben das führt mich dann
nachher noch zu der frage ob das
internet ein menschenrecht ist und zu
der frage nach vereinten nationen des
internets die auch zu einer politik der
digitalität gehören jetzt hatte ich
schon angekündigt es gibt von luciano
flori die 1 onlive manifester und das
möchte ich ihnen auch nicht verschweigen
ist dass ich das aus dass können sich
übrigens alle kostenlos herunterladen
des open access die onlive manifest
tobin jungen innerhalb connected er wir
hatten schon gesehen in diesem buch über
digitale aufklärung dass die vernetzung
einen ganz wichtigen bestandteil der
digitalisierung darstellen lest hier
wieder ein paar zitate vor dem central
station
development department of information
and communication technologies cities
das ist immer so die abkürzung in der
update
radikale effekte jugend condition ihn
sofort er ist mit motto relationship
store sales to understand the world the
increasing the
city safe system ist referenz
transformations als auch hier wird für
eine dysfunktion
argumentiert die aber eben nicht nur
wirtschaftlich oder konkret materiell zu
verstehen sondern abstrakter im sinne
von rahmenbedingungen oder
begrifflichkeiten die dadurch in
bewegungen gehabt und das sind jetzt
diese punkte die er nennt zum einen die
play off the stage in between realisiert
wird
realität und virtualität werden immer
mehr verwischt da hab ich wieder was
auszusetzen das würde ich einfach nicht
unterschreiben weil die sich nicht auf
derselben ebene befinden realität und
virtualität sind nicht gleichbedeutend
von ihrer hierarchie so wird realität
ist eine form von realität als eine
unter ist der realität untergeordnet wie
es eben auch physikalische physische
realität gibt aber grundsätzlich stimme
ich zu dass es immer mehr virtuelle
realität gibt durch diese entwicklung
zwei
junge machine manager
bin ich mir auch nicht so ganz sicher
und dann möchte ich nicht so ganz
zustimmt selbst wenn künstliche
intelligenz immer mehr um sich greift
und einsatz findet heißt es ja nicht
dass diese künstliche intelligenz
menschlicher ist dennoch würde ich sagen
künstliche intelligenz wird man mehr
teilen zur lebenswelt so würde ich
arrangiere
dressel von informations chaos city zu
informationen bundles also city also es
geht darum dass wir jetzt immer mehr
information haben ein übermaß an
informationen und
das schiff von der primacy auf nbc
stuart price of interaction das ist eine
unter logische these von luciano florida
gesagt im rahmen der digitalität der
digitalen entwicklung geht es nicht mehr
so sehr um substanzen um dinge das wäre
das ihr physikalische paradigma dass ich
dinge anfassen kann sondern es geht
immer mehr um relationen aber es ist
vernetzt nichts ist mehr wirklich stabil
ist alles ist auch in bewegung ja das
ist eine sehr generelle these die man
jetzt im detail mit der physisch
diskutieren müsste ich würde sie es so
auch nicht gleich unterschreiben aber
darauf müssen wir nicht mehr jetzt
eingehen ich möchte jetzt hier noch ein
paar thesen bringen die er dieses onlive
dass es eben auch ein begriff der für
die sehr treffend eingeführt hat also
online und onlive auf diese trennung
zwischen lebenswelt und internet wird
immer mehr aufgehoben die internet als
virtuelle handlungsraum zitat ist meine
feste aims to learn schoben die berät
und impact auf der computational and
public spaces politics and
expectations toward policymaking in
politischer agenda auf unix mehr mit an
bord ist meine festivalstart reflexion
und the witcher connected world calls
for i think the french space & witsch
polizist robert
blake in florida hat hier sich auch sehr
für die politische dimension der
digitalisierung interessiert ich mache
unten dann im beschreibungstext einen
link zu einem center seinem aufsatz von
florida hinein der europa- und seine
digitale zukunft betrifft
jetzt hat er hier eine überschrift
becoming the digital age 2 die ludwig
also gebildet obwohl der deutsche
bildungsbegriff nicht ganz
bestimmt was ist jetzt also das ziel wie
können wir digital gebildet werden er
sagt zitat die utopia of science and
only patents auf details in instrumente
edit wars ja dann entdecken porsche des
christbaums endlich die story to a
series of its forces in experience sind
topix fiel in der folge relativ das can
be used to instruments
policies mannsbilder connect critical
mass tk-chef auch juristen politiker
structures die prämie die bei
technologies geißinger das von sybille
die hypo connected reality requires
coaching connections per session
intentions moralität ihren corporate
fashion or if technologies in general
citizen botticelli development of
critical relationship neue tiefs
schüttelt er mit finding the change up
lässt zahlt dies meditations
betreiber hätten immer nennt
understanding av technologies shape and
humans and humans critical chain
technologies
finde ich sie überzeugen es geht um ein
wechselverhältnis von technologie und
mensch wir verändern die technik die
technik aber auch uns geht um ein
wirklich sehr enges verhältnis was wir
immer auch lebensweltlich verstehen
müssen dem stimme ich zu jetzt möchte
ich abschließend oder vorläufig
abschließend noch auf das thema
künstliche intelligenz und politik zu
sprechen kann es gibt ein neues buch im
verlag mit dem titel freiheit und kalkül
die politik der algorithmen natürlich
betrifft nicht nur das internet als
großer trend
der digitalität die politik sollen auch
künstliche intelligenz an ich würde
sagen internet und künstliche
intelligenzen zu 2d digitalen phänomene
die am philosophischen interessantesten
sind damit möchte ich nichts sagen dass
es nicht auch noch andere philosophisch
zugriffe gibt zb auf software oder auf
computerspiele und so weiter die karts
werden digitale gesellschaften digitale
revolutionen oder gar ein neues
zeitalter der digitalisierung ausgerufen
geht es nur am rande darum dass ich
gesellschaft weltgeschichte binärcode
ihren also in den zahlen wird 0 und 1
vollständig beschreiben ließen der
binären code die allem zugrunde liegende
sprache der computer steht weniger
erfolg und als ein anderer staat
digitale techniken machen soziales leben
nicht nur effizienter schneller und
bequemer sondern verändern es auf eine
grundlegend weise dass die art und das
ausmaß der veränderung bislang kaum
fassbaren digitalisierung wird
entsprechend mit ähnlichen revolution
mit der entwicklung der schrift des
buchdrucks oder der elektrizität
wirklich digitale techniken greifen
zweifellos ähnlich weit aus wie die
genannten mädchen techniken
digitalisierung stimmte hier
kommunizieren handeln produzieren und
konsumieren wie wir lesen hören und
sehen kurz wie wir wahrnehmen doch
digitalisierung greift noch tiefer ein
und weiter aus indem sie uns
alternativen zu unserem denken anbietet
auch in bezug darauf wie wir uns als
menschen erfüllen allein und in
gesellschaft hier würde ich auch sehr
zustimmen bei der ganzen philosophischen
debatte um digitalität
digitalisierung geht es nicht nur moment
1 ich würde sagen was sie jetzt
beschreibt dass die digitale technik
unser leben verändert das ist eigentlich
die digitalität also null und eins diese
ganzen technischen gingen die
betreffende digitalisierung von dem das
sie jetzt hier spricht redet man
eigentlich im sinne von digitalität zu
ist zumindest eine unterscheidung waren
diese vorlesung zu verstehen noch ein
zitat doch sollten wir digitale technik
nicht alleine aus der perspektive ihrer
technik sieht als eine neue form von
technik unter vielen anderen technik
verstehen denn sie verändern nicht nur
uns menschen dann auch alle übrigen
techniken die wir kennen von
fortbewegung über kommunikation zu
fertigen
erkenntnis techniken bis hin zu sozialen
techniken es reicht also ebenso wenig
aus sicht der digitalisierung nur aus
dem blickwinkel der digitalität zu
nähern bild doch die bloße möglichkeit
der repräsentation oder anders der
verdopplung der welt vom einzelnen
beziehungs verhältnissen oder
informationen in der binären codierung
bestehend aus mainz nicht den kern
dessen was der begriff der
digitalisierung beschreibt hier ist mir
jetzt nicht ganz klar was sie unter
digitalität verstehen sie scheint den
jetzt hier nur
technisch zu verstehen ich finde er wird
nicht ganz klar verwendet wir müssen
schauen wie sieht noch weiter darüber
spricht das ist aber jetzt nur eine
randbemerkung und nicht das einzige
thema dieses buches anders und motiv
diese bewegung bildet einerseits die
annahme das digitalisierte und genau an
diesem ort eine besondere eine
politische relevanz entfaltet diese
relevanz zeitlich nicht nur darin dass
die technische entwicklung zum
gegenstand für politik wird soll vor
allem darin dass digitalisierung selbst
sich als politischer prozesse stehen
lässt ich würde hier eben sagen
digitalität ist ein politischer prozess
und nicht digitalisierung in dem
gegenwärtigen debatten und um und
gesellschaftlichen auseinandersetzung
mit techniken künstliche intelligenz ist
außerdem zu beobachten dass ethische
haftungsrechtliche und ökonomische
fragen zwar durchaus behandelt werden
die politische dimension diese techniken
aber kaum beachtet den würde ich
durchaus zustimmen
im folgenden wird es darum gehen wie
sich die politik der algorithmen genauer
beschreiben lässt und wie wir als
gesellschaft mit den entsprechenden
problemen umgehen können die
alkoholisierung transformiert
gesellschaften fundamental erst wenn wir
diese veränderung besser verstehen
können wir politisch selbstbestimmt auf
die entsprechenden herausforderung
reagieren potenzial erkennen und
verantwortungsvoll handeln halte ich
auch für sehr sehr berechtigt diesen
punkt und auch das philosophische
anliegen eben die digitalität auch
stärker unter politischen
gesichtspunkten zu betrachten
algorithmen jetzt geht es zum
eigentlichen thema algorithmen erheben
wahrscheinlichkeit zum prinzip der
weltdeutung unterbinden dieses prinzip
mit einer spezifischen version des
verhältnisses von kollektivität und
individualität in dem sie der logik von
input und output den anscheinend von
neutralität geben auf diese weise
entwickeln sie ein anderes paradigma der
ordnungs bildung das sich deutlich von
den paradigmen liberaler westliche
politische fassung unterscheidet dieses
angebot ist bereits strukturell normativ
angelegt und vom wird insofern soziale
ordnung bildung wird also durch die
normativität der normalisierung
politisch algorithmen stellen den
grundsätzen politischer autor wie und
freiheit ein anderes modelle gegenüber
dieses modell entwickelt sich in dem es
die soziale bild ausgreifend durchdringt
zu einer konkurrenz für die idee
politische freiheit es muss also das
verhältnis zwischen mobilität und
herrschaft genauer untersucht werden die
besondere potenzial tät des modells
lässt sich schließlich als
entpolitisierung beschreiben also hier
ist eine ganz klare kritik an der künste
intelligenz aus politischer perspektive
formuliert nämlich das karree immer
schon
normativ sdms wahrscheinlichkeit zur
normalität erhebt und auch die
anscheinend von neutralität wickelt
spricht hier hinterfragen häufig nicht
genug die prinzipien die künstliche
intelligenz zugrunde liegt und das hat
natürlich auch auswirkungen auf die
politik wenn kalli immer mehr in unsere
lebenswelt eingang findet
jetzt möchte ich hier noch eine politik
des internets kurz charakterisieren nach
meinen begriffen der digitalität das
internet ist ein virtueller
handlungsraum der freien entfaltung und
verwirklichung ermöglicht das kann man
sich fragen warum sollte diese freiheit
nur bestimmten menschen zu kommen
faktisch ist es ja so wir haben
statistiken gesehen bezogen von rupp wie
viele menschen in verschiedenen ländern
internetzugang haben hier gibt es ein
ganz klares nord-süd-gefälle
warum sollten also nur manche menschen
in manchen regionen der welt freiheit im
sinne des virtuellen handlungs raubs
haben anti nicht man könnte jetzt
traditionellerweise so argumentiert
sagen die technik kann halt nicht
überall sein das alter ist doch nur
technik um andere länder haben da für
andere bereiche mehr natur nicht so viel
pech das wäre jetzt in meinen augen zu
kurz gegriffen weil man hier diesen
freiheits aspekt übersehen würde der mit
dem internet eben wesentlich einhergeht
das heißt es fehlen vom internet ist
nicht nur ein technisches ein
technisches technischer faktor und das
fehlen des internets ist ein politischer
faktor der die menschenrechtssituation
dieser länder betrifft
das internet verkörpert in meinen augen
idee der vereinten nationen auf
paradigmatische weise
warum weil das internet uns alle
demokratisch in eine verbindung setzt
ersetzen werden deswegen sollte das
internet keine nationale sondern eine
internationale
angelegenheit sein das war die debatte
nach oben rechts den wind grenze die
sitzung über ethik der digitalität haben
wir diese menschenrechte die digitalen
diskutiert und in diesem zusammenhang
auf die frage dazu genommen ob wir ein
nationales internetminister und
benötigen das würde ich jetzt
einschränkend bejahen nur insofern als
dieses nationale internet medizin in
einem verhältnis einem verbund steht von
internationalen system und unter dem
dach der vereinten nationen das wird in
meinen augen der struktur des internets
gericht nicht nationale alleingänge das
führt hier zu einer zu verkürzten sicht
auf die
wesentlich internationale auch inter
subjektive dimension des internets die
keine nationalen grenzen kennt selbst
datei selbst domain-endungen punkt de
lassen sich sehr wohl international
nutzen zb wenn man diesen punkt de
als bestandteil eines namens auf fast
geben durch die änderungen uhr
fortgesetzt zum beispiel ende ist das
ließe sich auch mit anderen sprachen so
denken die durch deutsche endung
plötzlich vervollständigt wird auf eine
originelle weiß ja nur als beispiel
freie zugang zum internet und demokratie
stehen einen engen verhältnis ich glaube
dass das internet wie gesagt nicht nur
medium ist auch nicht nur virtuelle
handlungsraum damit jetzt nur einen
schritt weiter gehen das internet ist
eine demokratische struktur die wenn sie
nur genug sich ausdehnt und im
vernetzung gebracht wird demokratie
vergrössern das wären meine these die
natürlich durchaus stark ist so jetzt
habe ich hier meine thesen präsentiert
über die wir jetzt gleich treffen
diskutieren können ich möchte zum
schluss auf die letzte sitzung die
letzte vorlesung diesem semester
hinweisen in der es um die zukunft der
digitalität gehen soll denn jetzt nicht
nur sinne einer spekulation nicht im
sinne von irgendwelchen singularitäten
die ich jetzt hier irgendwie vorhersagen
möchte das kann überhaupt nicht sondern
im sinne von entwicklung wie wir sie
jetzt finden die jetzt nicht
exponentiell eine singularität anton die
er im sie mit der horizontalen
verschmelzung der immer weiter
zunehmenden lebensweg in vernetzung
verpflichtung zu verstehen und hier zum
einen das metaversum den begriff haben
sicherlich schon gehört der ist jetzt
immer mehr in einer runde mark
zuckerberg verwendet ihn das metaversum
als zukunft des internets möchte die
frauen also ist das der weg wohin das
internet führt ich würde es begann so
wie kann ich schon sagen sie wissen
nicht versteht das internet als
handlungsraum als virtuellen dann möchte
ich einen trend noch behandelt nämlich
virtuelle realität als realität zu
verstehen und nicht als simulation und
schließlich onlive als lebensform das
heißt möchte ein blick darf auch
phänomenologische dürfen auf unseren
wie dort digitalen medien immer mehr
integriert werden und immer weniger als
medien- oder instrumente werden das ist
also der ausblick auf die letzte sitzung
wenn sie noch fragen oder vorschläge
haben können sie mir gerne jederzeit
perrine die selten ich werde sie dann
aufnehmen dann bedanke ich mich für die
aufmerksamkeit und bin jetzt sehr
gespannt auf die diskussion